just hearing it through a statement
we're seven weeks in now a bit too much
too little too late I'm afraid
do you feel new suffering unnecessarily
because of the actions of the US
authorities you know whoever made that
decision we do not know but we shouldn't
have gone through this we shouldn't be
suffering like this it should have been
an open-and-shut case the evidence is
extremely clear what happened then we've
been told that there are CCTV evidence
showing her leaving RAF Croton on the
wrong side of the road and that CCTV
follows her all the way down the road on
the wrong side of the road and you see
Harry's headlight of his motorbike and
then there's a big fireball when his
bike went up so it should have been a
clear-cut case it should have been
simple and I promised Harry and we
promised Harry as a family when we lost
him that night when we were talking to
him in the hospital and we'd lost him
already that we would make sure justice
was done we thought it would be an easy
one an easy case with all the evidence
that the Northamptonshire police have
but clearly not and that's why we're
here
we just want to know that she's being
brought back to the UK you know that
would be a huge step in the right
direction it's the only right thing to
do it's the only humane thing to do and
we would hope then that we can try to
start to move forward and UK justice
system do whatever they feel is right
because with it being seven weeks later
we're not sure if we can be involved
with trying to reduce her sentence which
is what we said we would do in the first
place they wanted to pursue her or
charged her with death by dangerous
driving we spoke to the police right at
the beginning knowing that she had
children we were going to work with them
ask for her sentence to be reduced to
death by careless and asked for us
suspended so that we could didn't take
her away from her children although
she's robbed us of one of ours it wasn't
unintentional it was an accident
we understand that but seven weeks on
and we've had to do this to get an
apology just in writing it's just wrong
what you might say throws a coulis if
you were given the opportunity I've
always wanted to ask her if she could
explain the moment of the crash find out
if she comforted Harry if she spoke to
Harry find out what her movements were
did she try and call the emergency
services or I just I just struggling
because I can't imagine my that being in
the ditch and not having any comfort
from anybody until the ambulance and the
police turn up next minutes later when
we had the funeral which was a lovely
tribute to him I thought maybe that was
the time we were going to turn the
corner but then it wasn't until a week
later when we found out that she'd left
the country and now it feels like it's
just gone right back to that night he
died and it's just no way I could start
grieving you as a family we can't start
we need need this resolved we do need
this resolved
in my opinion they knew she did have I'm
sorry but this so much not right here
this is just somewhere somewhere
somebody's made a decision to give this
lady immunity and she's no child to the
immunity as things have been said and
we've known that from the start we we
knew from the start
they've made a mistake someone's made a
mistake just to me it's so so simple
it's just on that night there was an
accident
a lady made a mistake she killed her son
she didn't mean to kill if she didn't
mean to have the accident but you cannot
walk away from that and just leave and
expect nothing to happen a boy died he
deserves to have some justice whatever
that says out to be oh you hear if
you're some world was to die you would
want justice for your child and that's
all we want we don't want you want
justice we want justice for Harry
I would just say to him as a man as a as
a you know father thank you just to see
how it is how could you let this happen
if you were a father and your child had
died surely you'd want that person to
own up and take the responsibility of
their actions